You see them at work, on the bus, I've even
seen them on airplanes.
E-cigs are everywhere, are they REALLY that
awesome?
E-cigarettes are everywhere and new studies
on vaping come out all the time.
If somehow you're unfamiliar, vapes involve
three pieces, a battery, container of liquid,
and a heating element.
This simple device can be used to deliver
everything from tobacco or THC to flavored
mists and caffeine.
The Vapor Market in the U.S. hit an estimated
2.5 billion dollars -- 60 percent of which
was just for customizable mods and juices.
Over the last five years, aggressive marketing,
and limiting of the cigarette market has caused
the market to explode.
That being said, there are precious few regulations
or studies exploring what vaping is doing
to the inside of users, especially over the
long term; and NO studies on long-term exposure
in living animals.
The American Heart Association weighed in
last May -- and it wasn't awesome for fans
of vaping -- you can check out Laci's video
for some background on that, but since then
-- more has come to light.
The latest study to ROCK the vaping world
comes out of Johns Hopkins - researchers exposed
mice to vapor from e-cigs.
To do so, they used a modified smoking machine
which inhaled for 2 seconds once every 10
seconds.
Other studies have found smokers showed a
biomarker called cotinine; so they exposed
the mice to a concentration of nicotine that
would produce similar nicotine biomarkers
to a heavy smoker.
They even measured the entirety of the vapor
and mixed it with filtered air before exposing
the mice for 1.5 hours a day total over two
weeks.
They also exposed some mice to just regular
air.
They found there are over 700 billion particulate
free radials per puff of a vape.
Normally, free radicals are a product of heating,
so these are actual particles that will enter
the lungs and QUOTE "could be potentially
toxic to cells."
Though more research is needed to determine
that toxicity.
Aside from that, they exposed the mice to
the bacteria which cause pneumonia, or the
influenza virus -- our little friend the flu.
As you've probably guessed, this study doesn't
go well for vapes, the lead researcher says
the lungs ARE definitely affected by the chemicals
in liquid nicotine e-cigs.
The mice who were vaping had lung inflammation
and protein damage; and when exposed to infection
their defenses were significantly reduced.
The mice were unable to clear bacteria from
their lungs, and those with the flu experienced
weight loss and some died!
It's important to point out, this is one type
of vape, there are many iterations and mods
available which might change the results -- and
they each require their own scientific scrutiny.
Studies have conclusively shown, however,
that vapor DOES contain free radicals, formaldehyde,
and other carcinogens.
On average, e-cigs contain only 1-percent
the number of chemicals of an average cigarette,
but even THAT surprised the researchers since
manufacturers claim otherwise.
In the end, the scientific community and the
regulatory community are still trying to figure
this crap out.
Queen Mary University of London published
a piece in Addiction which said regulating
e-cigs the same way as tobacco isn't necessary
because of their vast differences.
At the same time, both the American Heart
Association and Food and Drug Administration
encourage cigarette-like regulations!
Frankly, the medical community is very clear;
in comparison to smoking cigarettes, vaping
IS better, but that doesn't mean it gets a
gold star.
Looks like science has some work to do.
What do you think?
We followed up on this because Nexy_Dre and
Saurini wanted to know more!
If you have anything you want to know
about tell us!